[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 sél édition de la
rédaction pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale et régionale voici
les titres de ce jeudi 20 juin les
anciens de l'estaca de retour ce matin
l'école d'ingénieurs spécialisée dans
l'e mobilité célébrer sa promotion 1969
neuf personnes diplômées il ya 50 ans
ont fait le déplacement campus de
montigny le bretonneux
ce réseau honoré lui sa promotion 2018
entreprendre yvelines a organisé cette
semaine ça fait des lauréats 27
créateurs de sociétés accompagné par la
structure ont été récompensés et il s'en
va après dix ans passés à la tête du
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir
vincent desmons prend sa retraite une
carrière entièrement dédié à la culture
c'est le portrait de la semaine
dans ce journal nous parlerons également
des personnes âgées et du lien
intergénérationnel avec la création de
ce projet à versailles les grands
s'amusent et puis la fête de l'été ce
dimanche c'est à saint rémy les
chevreuse à montigny le bretonneux
l'école d'ingénieurs de l'estac a
accueilli aujourd'hui une ancienne
promotion celle de 1969 9 ex étudiants
qui ont obtenu leur diplôme il ya 50 ans
eu le droit à une visite du campus et
elle a été suivie cette visite par
aurélien cette structure métallique
installée dans le fab lab de l'estaca
est assez familière pour ce groupe
d'étudiants
il s'agit de l'ancien logo de l'école
d'ingénieurs qui à leur époque en 1969
était situé à paris
cinquante ans après le réseau estaca
l'umih a organisé une visite du campus
de montigny le bretonneux non nakhonay
larry boudreault il s'agit d'un 5ème
arrondissement il ya quatre salles de
cours
et autres or quand on voit ici là le
volume le confort le matériel installé
etc
je pense qu'on n'a pas trop mal
travaillé à l'époque pour développer
cette activité
en plus des locaux cette visite a
également été l'occasion de découvrir
les projets portés par les actuels
étudiants
exemple avec l'association pv 3e qui
conçoit un véhicule capable de parcourir
le plus de kilomètres avec un seul litre
d'essence
c'était très intéressant de voir des
étudiants qui sont qui étaient là avant
nous qui connaissent bien le l'idée sur
la sur quoi on travaille ça vient la
housse peuvent être les gains ils ont
parlé des roulements de l'aérodynamisme
des pertes moteur donc il on voyait
qu'il connaissait bien le sujet après
l'obtention de leur diplôme en juillet
1969 certains ont embrassé une carrière
dans l'automobile d'autre dans
l'aéronautique
ils ont malgré tout toujours gardé
contact on s'est toujours but a toujours
vues autour d'eux au cours de notre vie
quoi quelles que soient les endroits où
on était dans le nord de france ou même
à l'étranger ont été toujours on a
toujours trouvé les moyens de chute de
cheveux
une expérience qu'il serait prêt à
renouveler ça peut-être en fauteuil
roulant la prochaine on espère
[Musique]
c'est jusqu'à dimanche à paris le
bourget le salon international de
l'aéronautique et de l'espace la
présidente de la région valérie pécresse
s'est rendue sur place hier pour
affirmer la première place de l'île de
france dans le secteur depuis 2016 la
collectivité a investi plus de 30
millions d'euros pour l'aéronautique est
forfait sur la formation avec la
création de deux campus des métiers
l'enez sun l'autre en seine et marne et
val d'oise investissements également
pour la recherche
écoutez valérie pécresse au micro de
maths finances de nos confrères de radio
sensations
l'île de france est la première région
aéronautique de france et ça se sait pas
du tout assez nous avons cent cinq mille
emplois 2000 entreprises et donc et bien
évidemment il faut qu'on les soutienne
on va les soutenir comme ans en
organisant des campus des métiers de la
formation sur les métiers de
l'aéronautique qui jusqu'à présent
n'existait pas par ailleurs si on veut
développer la filière aéronautique il
faudrait aider la recherche dans
l'aéronautique et c'est pour ça que nous
venons de signer avec air france la
création d'un laboratoire de maintenance
prédictive
parce que air france maintenance la
maintenance des avions c'est 8000
emplois en ile de france
c'est une filière énorme qui pourrait
croître et embellir autour de autour de
roissy
sa vocation faire émerger et réussir de
nouveau à créateurs et repreneurs
d'entreprises plus de 45 personnes sont
en cours d'accompagnement par le réseau
entreprendre yvelines
cette semaine il a célébré sa promotion
en 2018 marylène iapichino et nicolas
d'andré ils sont 27 lauréats des
entrepreneurs accompagnés par le réseau
entreprendre yvelines réunis pour
célébrer cette promotion 2018
au quotidien en fait on a on a un
programme mensuel d'accompagnement est
donc un non-membre chef d'entreprise la
plupart du temps en activité les suit au
mois le mois pour revoir avec eux d'une
façon je dirais effet miroir
quels sont les problèmes qui est ce qui
pourrait y avoir comme solution mais
jamais jamais jamais on prend la
décision à leur place c'est eux qui
prennent la décision
un parcours d'accompagnement entre deux
et trois ans pour des projets très
variés
thème de la soirée pensée ambitions j'ai
toujours eu cette envie de partir d'une
idée pour arriver jusqu'à voilà la
réalisation quelque chose de concret à
vendre à des idées qui nécessite du
temps après trois années de recherche et
développement le réseau et des mama faux
minianne à commercialiser son système de
complémentaire santé pour les proches de
la diaspora africaine est resté au
continu un ami avec qui je travaillais
un copain ingénieurs il a perdu sa maman
qui souffre d'un cancer parce qu'elle ne
pouvait pas été traités sur place
et là c'était le déclic qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose et nous avons pensé
accueillez diaspora santé lancée en 2018
sa plateforme est déjà utilisé dans 13
pays différents
moi je trouve qu'il ya une génération
d'entrepreneurs et d'entrepreneur re au
féminin exceptionnelle qui a envie de
changer le monde qui est qu'ils auront
une ambition pas seulement pour eux pas
seulement pour gagner de l'argent qui
même plus là le premier moteur de la
création d'entreprise pour eux le réseau
entreprendre yvelines fêtera ses 10 ans
en octobre prochain
il contribue à la création d'emplois
dans le département les entreprises du
département qui était invité à un temps
d'information ce matin au ski cube à
guyancourt la préfecture des yvelines
présentait lé dispositif de l'état en
faveur de l'insertion professionnelle
dans les quartiers de la politique de la
ville et des territoires où le taux de
chômage est plus important il frôle les
40% par exemple chez les jeunes à
mantes-la-jolie trois dispositifs ont
été plus particulièrement détaillé le
plan à dix mille entreprises les emplois
francs qui apporte une aide financière
aux sociétés qui embauchent un habitant
d'un quartier prioritaire 15000 euros
sur trois ans pour un emploi en cdi ou
encore
le pacte pour mettre davantage en
relation jeunes et entreprises les
propos sont collectées par aurélien bien
plusieurs actions ça peut être par
exemple pour pour les jeunes collégiens
trouver un stage de 3e vraiment de
qualité qui soit pas juste le commerçant
empêcher la possibilité d'aller dans des
grandes entreprises ou dans des services
publics dont ils n'ont pas forcément
connaissance s'est aussi essayé de
promouvoir l'alternance qui est on le
sait vraiment un levier important pour
ces jeunes pour pouvoir accéder à
l'emploi est également sensibiliser les
entreprises sur des achats responsables
qui peuvent être effectués vraiment
localement et pas forcément à à l'autre
bout du monde mais plus d'informations
sur ces dispositifs sur le site internet
de la préfecture des yvelines
on parle à présent dans ce journal du
lien social plus précisément le lien
inter générationnel avec mes invités
autour de la table jennyfer caron et
dominique jourdaine bonsoir restez avec
nous on parle dans un instant avec vous
de la fête de l'été qui se déroule ce
dimanche à saint rémy les chevreuse
bonsoir anne bouchard l'a en sa
et vous êtes vous avez lancé à
versailles les grands s'amusent alors
c'est un projet de socialisation et de
divertissement pour les personnes âgées
qui passe notamment par la transmission
c'est un projet qui part d'un constat
300000 personnes âgées qui sont en
situation de mort sociale en france
d'après une étude de l'institut csa
c'est ça et puis c'est aussi le constat
ce que la plupart des seigneurs des
personnes âgées veulent rester chez eux
le plus tard possible
et voilà donc
il faut les il faut il faut les occuper
elles souffrent d'isolement ces
personnes âgées
ouais il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
plaignent d'être des deux seuls ils ont
les familles sont éclatées aujourd'hui
les ont pas tous ceux
beaucoup d'amis ou des amis qui ont
disparu donc c'est donc effectivement
par exemple en art pas seul c'est un peu
triste
ouais ouais donc l'idée c'est vraiment
de de recréer du lien social et de les
mettre en réseau valeurs seuils
si on pose le constat aussi c'est que la
population des seniors et 21% cei à 21 2
% de seniors à versailles plus de 60 ans
exactement
ouais et donc c'est pour ça vous le
lancez à versailles a besoin de succès
deviendrait besoin moi c'est un secteur
que je connais bien parce que je vis à
versailles depuis plus d'un an
voilà donc j'ai constaté par les
commerçants par par des médecins des
infirmières que voilà il y avait
beaucoup de personnes isolées
justement pourquoi avoir créé ce projet
c'est sur le terrain vous avez vu qu'il
y avait dans ses rangs et puis moi
il ya quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
c'est le fait que chacun a sa place dans
la société
pour moi les seniors ce sont des trésors
ils ont énormément de choses à
transmettre
on l'oublié un petit peu et de dire
voilà
transmettez nous vos expériences vos
passion un métier que vous avez exercé
vous avez adoré qui peut-être a disparu
aujourd'hui c'est c'est nos mémoires
donc c'est l'idée c'est que ça ça ça
continue et que et qu'on puisse profiter
de leur expérience dans ce projet je le
rappelle si les grands s'amusent
quel est l'objectif est aussi quel est
le principe de ce projet alors
l'objectif c'est vraiment de justement
leur redonner confiance qui de leurs
recréer du lien social par cette
transmission est ensuite qu'ils puissent
justement être en meilleure santé et
avoir un meilleur moral et ses terrains
et l'idée c'est que ça se fasse à leur
domicile chez les uns chez les autres il
y en a qui sont vraiment prêts à ouvrir
leurs portes et de refaire vivre un peu
leur intérieur leur coco voilà donc moi
je décèle des talents chez les uns chez
les autres et on choisit on définit un
thème à l'avancé on va parler de ce
thème ensemble mais c'est un projet que
les touristes ont il a été lancé il ya
deux mois exactement
ouais voilà donc
j'ai beaucoup de retours très positifs
donc je pense que
voilà ça va comment ils sont un peu
justement ce projet vous l'avez dit vous
détectez des talons des talents chez les
uns chez les autres
alors pour démarrer j'ai en fait j'ai
identifié dès ce que j'appelle des
passeurs d'expérience ce sont des des
intervenants extérieurs qui ont en
général une carrière professionnelle
intéressante ou des patients intéressant
donc je leur fais je les fais intervenir
pour les les ateliers les premiers
ateliers en tout cas est ensuite jamie
mais je demande aux différents grands de
vagues de s'exprimer sur le sujet il
s'adresse seulement ou versailles est
pour dans un premier temps dans un
premier temps je démarre à versailles et
l'idée cdc mais et ça ça peut se faire
par tous donc voilà de quelle forme
elles prendront justement quelle forme
elle prenne ces séances jeu chez les
personnels
c'est un système d'adhésion à l'année
c'est comme je crée comme un le club des
grands c'est un petit peu ce que
j'aimerais faire c'est des salons
littéraires comme comme et 19e des
choses ou des salons ddd moment on va
pouvoir vraiment apprendre des uns des
autres des choses très intéressantes
c'est pas juste du bavardage se
retrouver entre eux puis bavarder mais
c'est vraiment apprendre des expériences
des uns et des autres donc c'est avec
quel type d'activité
par exemple elle s'est en fait c'est les
conférences sont d'accord c'est à dire
un ancien prof d'histoire va pouvoir
faire animer une conférence sur un thème
qu'on aura des finales avance une
ancienne prof de chant va proposer
pourquoi pas un cours de chant voilà ça
va être en fait une dynamique que je
vais mettre en place entre eux et qui va
se
j'espère le plus dynamique possible et
et puis et puis c'est mon rôle aussi
qu'ils me fassent confiance et que je
fasse le relais et je les cuis
s'exprimer le plus librement possible en
fait l'adhésion combien coûte-t-elle
alors sachant en train de finir enfin
l'attaquant s'est fixé comment on prend
contact avec vous comment on peut
effectivement intérêt en fait moi j'ai
pour l'instant j'ai une page
facebook dont ça c'est sophie championne
ou rsa s'adresse plus effectivement aux
enfants ces personnes là qui vont
pouvoir entrer en contact avec moi après
moi je connais que je communique
beaucoup sur les réseaux locaux
voilà comme par exemple gens de
confiance sur next door les réseaux de
voisinage et puis après c'est beaucoup
de prospection c'est vraiment je vais
voir les gens parce que comme c'est de
l'humain il faut qu'ils me fassent
confiance
donc je vais beaucoup chez les
commerçants jeu donc c'est un gros
boulot de
une prospection merci anne bouchard la
créatrice de ce projet les grands
s'amusent et je rappelle toutes les
informations sont à retrouver sur le
lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci c'est justement pour créer du lien
entre les générations qui est organisée
la fête de l'été elle se déroule
dimanche après midi au village
orpea de saint rémy les chevreuse avec
moi pour en parler jennyfer 40 et la
directrice d'exploitation de ce site et
dominique jourdaine qu'ea quatrième
maire adjoint de saint rémy les
chevreuse délégué aux affaires
familiales et sociales puisque on le dit
on le rappelle c'est un événement qui
est co organisé par le village seniors
par la ville de saint rémy les chevreuse
et aussi les associations du quartier
beauplan jennifer caron ouvrir la
résidence donné l'opportunité aussi à
ses résidents de créer du lien c'est
quelque chose d'important pour les
élèves chose d'important c'est quelque
chose qu'on véhicule depuis de
nombreuses années le groupe orpea
toujours été attaché à développer les
liens intergénérationnels qui permet ce
qui permet effectivement de créer du
lien social comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure mais aussi
ça participe à l'épanouissement des
personnes en perte d'autonomie et sa
part mais aussi de changer le regard de
la société sur les personnes vivant en
ehpad je vous fait réagir par parce que
dizaine dont je me bouchard là c'est oui
c'est quelque chose d'important pour ces
personnes âgées de garder un contact
garder du lien garder sa place dans la
société
garder du lien social et transmettre
effectivement les enfants et change
énormément avec les personnes âgées les
personnes âgées ont beaucoup de choses à
leur dire et alors laissé en mémoire
d'accord avec vous et du côté de la
commune de saint rémy les chevreuse
pourquoi s'associer à ce projet ce que
ça rentre tout à fait dans notre choix
politique envers les seniors on a de la
chance d'avoir d'excellentes relations
avec le madame caron et donc le glas
chez un européen et donc c'était tout à
fait naturel que on a souhaité
s'associer à cette grande fête pour
justement l'intergénérationnel parce que
c'est un peu mon cheval de bataille sur
donc sur notre mandat et c'est tellement
sympathique de voir les jeunes et les
personnes âgées communiquer et échanger
ensemble donc voilà ça me paraissait
tout à fait opportun et et naturel de le
faire non d'autant plus que l'animation
rentre tout à fait dans le cadre
convivial de la fête de la musique au
programme qui était prévu à saint rémy
les chevreuse ce week-end tout à fait
vendredi samedi et dimanche donc on aura
trois jours de festivités de ces
festivités avec un angle
intergénérationnel pour le dimanche donc
un événement événement
intergénérationnel mais aussi solidaire
puisque les bénéfices de cet événement
seront reversés à une association je
vais y arriver imagine fort margot qui
soutient la recherche contre le cancer
des enfants
oui tout à fait alors l'association
imagine fort margot a été créé en 2010
et une association yvelinoise dont le
siège est à saint germain en laye c'est
une association qui récolte des fonds et
qui les utilisent de manière très
transparente en faveur de la recherche
pour le cancer effectivement des enfants
faut savoir qu'en france aujourd'hui on
a à peu près 500 enfants qui décède d'un
cancer chaque année 6000 enfants en
europe et
l'argent récolté par l'association
imagine forme fort margot permet de
financer des programmes innovants et
spécifiques en faveur des enfants et des
adolescents
donc le lien intergénérationnel ongles
également solidaires comment s'est monté
le projet il s'est monté avec les
associations du quartier de beauplan
c'est ça mais où est situé le village
c'est naturel nous sommes un peu
coutumier du fait je dirais puisque le
village orpea de saint rémy les
chevreuse et surtout un lieu de vie
c'est un village dans la ville en fête
et nous avons l'habitude d'organiser des
événements et collaboré au travers de la
politique seniors de la commune et on
organise régulièrement des ateliers par
exemple culinaire intergénérationnel des
concerts de musique ou autre à
destination à la fois des seniors vivant
dans la commune et des seniors vivent
dans notre résidence
donc ça montre aussi toute l'activité
des associations de saint rémy les
chevreuse oui tout à fait on se tenait
absolument de soutenir valeur projet
parce que on a la chance à saint-rémy
d'avoir un tissu associatif très
important donc on est là pour les
soutenir dans leur projet c'est
important il vous qu'est-ce qui est au
programme de cette fête dimanche après
midi à côté c'est une fête de l'été donc
à l'aube des vacances d'été dans le
cadre de la fête de la musique on
organise
des stands de jeux dont il ya une
dizaine de stands de jeux alors on
retrouvera la pêche aux canards le tir à
la carabine jugeant boul'tout des
ateliers de maquillage des parcours
d'agilité pour les enfants des
barbapapas radis pop corn des
confiseries beaucoup de joie et bonne
humeur
donc on me l'a dit ça va mettre en avant
le tissu associatif de saint-rémy aussi
ses associations ses bénévoles pardon il
ya une cinquantaine de bénévoles qui
vont être mobilisés sur cet événement
pour la préparation pour animer aussi le
jour j oui effectivement on a préparé
cet événement donc avec la commune et
avec les associations donc notamment
l'association vivre les hauts de saint
rémy le lion de ce club de la vallée de
chevreuse dit aussi très dynamique sur
notre territoire
et puis les une association de parents
d'élèves de l'école jacquelin est donc
depuis déjà c'est un projet qui a été
initié au mois de décembre
bousquet déjà plusieurs mois que nous
travaillons à ce projet on a convié les
690 enfants deux scolarisés à saint remy
à venir partager ce moment avec nous et
ils ont donc on leur a offert une carte
de jeu ils pourront bénéficier
gratuitement des activités ce jour là
les ingrédients pour une première fête
de l'été réussie du soleil du soleil il
a béni la grande et donc cette fête de
l'été se déroule est dimanche c'est au
village seniors
orpea de saint rémy les chevreuse les
chevreuse rendez vous de 14 heures à 18
heures merci dominique jourdain et merci
à vous à jennyfer caron depuis 1982 elle
marque donc l'arrivée de l'été la fête
de la musique se déroule demain vendredi
programme chargé dans les yvelines voici
quelques-unes des animations du côté de
saint germain en laye les festivités
débutent dès 16 heures démonstration et
initiation de danses bretonnes puis rock
et variété française à voisins le
bretonneux les festivités sont à
retrouver de ka ka est quasiment minuit
terrasses en fête revient également à
maurepas à partir de 18h et direction
les états unis pour croissy-sur-seine
rock folk country dès 18h30 au skate
park à l'occasion de la coupe du monde
féminine de football et de la venue
prochaine de la sélection américaine sur
place et beaucoup de communes aussi
organisant leur fête de la musique le
programme est à consulter bien sûr sur
les ailes différencie
internet une page se tourne au théâtre
espace coluche après dix ans à sa tête
son directeur vincent desmons prend sa
retraite sa carrière il l'a entièrement
dédié à la dans d'autres salles mais
aussi sur les planches son portrait
signé par mélanie poker et mickaël
millero une répétition à la saveur
particulière
les 25 et 26 mai dernier la troupe jouer
double jeu et sur scène un comédien que
le public a peu l'habitude de voir dans
ce rôle quand vous aurez vendus aux
actions que je puisse venir avant bien
sûr vincent besson le directeur du
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir j'ai
jamais pensé une seconde déjà de
remonter sur scène j'avais pas du tout
l'idée que je le ferai il a fallu
qu'elle soit le metteur en scène vincent
collet qui me demande de le faire
mais alors qui de me retrouver ici à
jouer ici jamais j'ai imaginé une
seconde on n'a pas toujours s'acheter
des partenaires il est très franc du
regard il est
il joue avec avec ses partenaires il les
écoute
voilà c'est très agréable vincent besson
a dirigé la salle pendant dix ans il
prend sa retraite à l'issue de la saison
arrivé le 1er avril 2009 après plusieurs
années comme directeur des affaires
culturelles de provins de travailler
avec la personne qui était l'adjointe à
la culture à l'époque qui est madame le
maire aujourd'hui qui m'a tout de suite
blessé il ya une espèce de confiance qui
s'est installée donc j'ai une grande
liberté de programmation et ça c'est ça
j'ai jamais connu ça nulle part je peux
dire mot triste quand même parce que ça
fait dix ans dix ans c'est pas mal dans
une vie de collaboration aussi intense
avec une complicité forte très
importante une confiance aussi total
mais nous nous avions je dirais là mais
l'autre des goûts assez commun et puis
on a partagé des moments très très fort
à la fois joyeux et moins joyeux donc
c'est plus qu'un agent qui savent qu'ils
sont vastes et sa partenaire c'est un
artiste aussi depuis deux ans vincent
desmons remonte sur scène après dix sept
ans d'arrêt une passion commencé au
début de sa vie d'adulte l'aude sa
première envie celle de devenir avocat à
l'époque j'ai fait mon service militaire
et j'ai fait connaissance d'un garçon à
l'armée qu'est devenu mon meilleur ami
depuis et il m'a fait intégrer une
troupe de théâtre amateur
du coup j'ai enchaîné sur un cours de
comédie c'est jean laurent cochet où
j'ai appris énormément de choses
ils s'occupent très vite de sa première
salle à draveil le théâtre donald
cardwell le costumier américain et même
celui qui fera remonter vincent sur
scène à la fin de draveil j'ai de
nouveau oublier ça et puis j'ai
rencontré un
un jeune metteur en scène qui s'appelle
vincent rouvet qui est un des co
directeurs du théâtre darius milhaud à
paris et qui m'a dit mais as-tu va
bientôt être à la retraite il a eu là
une phrase kublai que j'aime beaucoup il
m'a dit tu sais qu'il ya plein de rôles
de vieux au théâtre la page plaisir oies
se tourne pour vincent desmo pour
retrouver son nom dans une programmation
il faudra dorénavant regarder du côté
des distributions et pour refermer ce
journal une découverte qui sent bon
l'été c'est le kayak-polo un sport qui
se pratique sur l'eau sur un kayak et le
principe émettre un maximum de buts une
journée du championnat régional de la
discipline s'est tenue tout récemment à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines les images de nicolas landry
[Musique]
c'est un sport qui mélange handball et
water-polo le tout se pratiquant à bord
d'un kayak le kayak polo se joue à cinq
contre cinq sur l'eau un match se divise
en deux mi temps de dix minutes
le principe mettre plus de points que
l'équipe adverse dans un but situé en
hauteur c'est du kayak alors faut savoir
faire du bateau et après dès qu'on prend
la balle en main on oublie le bateau
donc ce n'est pas ben kayak à la base on
n'arrive pas très bien à manoeuvrer et
ensuite après c'est un véritable sport
collectif
on est obligé de mettre en place des
tactiques des techniques pour pour pour
jouer comme dans tous les sports
collectifs de petits terrains pour
savoir où on est où son nouveau
coéquipier et savoir où on va surtout
pour aller vers le but et marqué les
gens qui sont plutôt attirés c'est les
familles les amis ont à dire les gens
qui passent parce que ils sont jamais vu
cette activité une journée du
championnat régional de ce sport se
dérouler à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines l'occasion de faire
connaître aux curieux cette discipline
encore méconnue
ça commence à se développer de plus en
plus surtout grâce aux jeux olympiques
les personnes se rapproche beaucoup de
des clubs de kayak après découvre des
activités comme le kayak polo qui n'est
pas diffusée à la télévision
attrapons pratiquer le kayak polo depuis
15 ans le club compte aujourd'hui une
centaine de licenciés
plus d'idées d'activités et de sorties
aussi à retrouver dans un instant le 7-8
loisirs présenté par marylène aya
piccino c'est la fin de ce journal
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver dès
lundi pour une nouvelle édition belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]